do you ponder your mortality
are you afraid of death i i do think
about it sometimes i mean it does pop
into my head sometimes
just the fact that uh i mean i'm 53
so if everything goes great i have less
than 50 years left
you know if everything goes great like
no car accidents no injuries
but it could happen today this could be
your last day it could be
that's kind of a stoic thing to meditate
on death
there's a there's a bunch of
philosophers ernest becker
and uh sheldon solomon they believe that
death
is the at the core of everything wrote
this book warm at the core
so does that come into play in the way
you see the world
i think having a sense of urgency is
very beneficial
and understanding that your time is
limited can aid you greatly
i think knowing that this is a temporary
time that we we have
finite life spans i i think there's a
there's great power in that because it
it motivates you it gets you going
i think being an immortal living forever
would be one of the most depressing
things particularly if everybody else
was dying around you
and i think one of the things that makes
life so
interesting and fascinating is that it
doesn't last
you know that you you really get a brief
amount of time here
and really by the time you're just
starting to kind of figure yourself out
who you are and how not to screw things
up so bad
like time's up the ride's over
you